turning to our next guest and a very
exciting announcement we are sharing
only on CBS mornings social media star
Charlie demilio and I will be co-hosting
Nickelodeon's Kids Choice Awards the
awards is taking place in March and will
celebrate fan favorites and film music
Sports and More Nickelodeon like CBS is
part of Paramount Global Charlie has
nearly 150 million followers on Tick
Tock and she has more than 11 billion
yep that's what the billion likes on her
videos she began sharing dance and lip
syncing videos in 2019 and became an
overnight sensation leading to a career
in music and business she has also been
endorsed by big companies like Duncan
Amazon and Prada together with the
sister Dixie she also launched a
clothing line Sally demilio joins us
right now how you doing
I'm good to say long time no sorry
yesterday hanging out yesterday yeah um
now you've been nominated for Kids
Choice Award before and you've attended
but it's a little bit different now
you're co-hosting oh yeah what are you
looking forward to oh my goodness I
think I'm most looking forward to seeing
everyone get slimed that's like
obviously the highlight of the show you
know who's on your list of possible
targets oh here we go I hope my entire
family gets slimed because I'm going to
bring them there and just watching them
that would be such a dream for me
Charlie you can make that happen yeah
you got some pool now now you can make
that happen you can't let them know
though now you've been to this type of
event it's it's a wild and crazy time
the Kids Choice Awards right oh yeah
what are some of the things you think
people should expect oh I think you can
expect
so many epic moments amazing guests
amazing nominees showing up music music
oh my goodness and obviously some
intense slimmings yeah but but Charlie
you are on such a fun ride I think I
remember taking my kids to the Kids
Choice Awards and I always loved it so
what's it like for you as someone who
probably watched it and now you're on
stage hosting it does it feel like a
pinch me moment for you to be on stage
doing this I mean two years ago was when
I was nominated and that itself I
immediately post this is no way
happen this is no way my life this is
not happening and then the next year I
got the honor of being nominated again
yeah and then this year when
I got the you know honor to be able to
co-host especially with you it's just
like every year it's just gets getting
crazier and crazier and it's such an
honor to be in that role and I'm so
excited crazy and crazier 150 million
followers on Tick Tock because I it's
literally a number that's hard to Fathom
oh yeah when you're holding that that
kind of audience in the palm of your
hand and thinking about what to post I
mean how do you decide what do you think
about I think for me you really have to
post for yourself if I you know got to
thinking about how many people even 1
million actually is watching the videos
that you post that I just make In My
Room by myself doing whatever yeah it's
really crazy I mean how do you even
understand that but let's start about
when you first did this for the very
first time because you're a great dancer
as we all know but when you were playing
around in your room with your sister
what were you guys thinking were you
thinking let's go big or were you
thinking this is just fun let's just
have fun with it I mean originally my
friends told me to get Tick Tock because
I was the dancer of the friend group and
they were like we need you to learn the
dances so you could teach them to us so
that was my job I was just you know
teaching them all the dancing the dance
were going viral yeah and then from
there it just snowballed and all of
these incredible things started to
happen and my sister started to you know
be in the picture more in my whole
family and now it's a family affair yeah
you make it look effortless thank you
speaking of incredible you won the Kids
Choice Awards for
um favorite female Creator last year and
you are nominated again this year this
year which is quite an honor how does
that feel to be nominated once again I
mean
it's so special to be you know
recognized alongside a group of people
that I love and all of my fellow social
creators yeah it's just you're up
against your little sister my big sister
yeah yeah I'm the little yeah which I
don't yeah I don't know how she feels I
mean we are sisters we're roommates we
spend every single day together
you know some friendly competition is
good but it's always good it's always
but you know what Charlie with all of
the good of social media there's always
haters people are just drinking cups of
hater age that come at you and everybody
else how do you handle that part of it I
think for me it's definitely keeping a
close-knit group of people around you
for me it's my family my hometown
friends they mean a lot to me you know
it's always good to have a conversation
with people that aren't really in this
world as much to just be like okay we
love you for you and I think that's very
special and don't take it in with people
that don't even know you that's right
for you yeah that's because I once her
haters gone hey yeah do what they do so
Emilio thank you so much I'll see you
soon right yes all right you can watch
the Kids Choice Awards live on Saturday
March 4th on Nickelodeon